[Música]
muchas gracias muchas gracias
pues mi propósito es sencillo que solo
en los espacios públicos de la ciudad
podemos realizar nuestro potencial como
ciudadanos en las relaciones que
desarrollamos con los demás está nuestra
verdadera
ser quienes somos está en esto por eso
que las ciudades tienen espacios
públicos de calidad es vital para que
tengamos civitas no la calle es el
espacio público por excelencia entendida
como una serie de arterias por donde nos
movemos yo propongo que puede ser
muchísimo muchísimo más y pregunto
cuando salimos a la compra estamos
abiertos a la serendipia
por la naturaleza de la calle cuando
vamos a congregar con con amigos estamos
dispuestos con la sensación de que la
ciudad nos invita a pasear a buscar
nuevos encuentros a conocer a personas
nuevas cuando caminamos por la calle
encontramos arte o monumentos o incluso
bromas graciosas con pintura en un
bolardo pregunto si encontramos ciudades
cuidadas donde uno puede pasear con
tranquilidad y paz con familiares
pregunto si la calle da lugar para el
juego de los niños o para el descanso de
la gente más mayor si la calle realmente
sirve para toda la población de la
ciudad
quiero hablar un poco de la importancia
de la del juego
porque por el juego libre por las las
calles los niños aprenden a las
lecciones más importantes de la
socialización
mientras negocian las reglas del juego y
cómo participar pues están aprendiendo
ser cívico ser atentos a lo demás a ser
sociables y estas son lecciones que son
para toda la vida
entonces desgraciadamente tenemos muchas
ciudades que no ofrecen este tipo de
espacio de encuentro porque sus calles
están dominadas por el uso del coche
privado no en otras en otros lugares el
problema de seguridad hace que los
medios que toman la gente más más rica
pues sirven de efectivamente matar la
vida callejera en san francisco en 1906
la bajísima velocidad de todos los modos
de transporte de la época hizo que la
calle en marquette que es lo que se ve
ahí la calle central más importante de
la ciudad se convirtió en un tipo de
campo libre no donde todos la gente en
el carruaje en bicicleta en tranvía o
andando se produza van se entrelazaban
sus caminos sin dificultad
miedo sin embargo se nota aún así que el
coche privado entra como el elemento más
temerario y su velocidad está todavía
bastante baja solo va a crecer pues uno
puede pensar que la evolución del
carácter de las calles ha sido en
nuestras ciudades algo natural no por
temas de tecnología pero la verdad es
que recibió un empujón con con su plan o
hacer para parís
se presentó esa idea de d
rascacielos rodeados de parques y
avenidas y carreteras y hasta autopistas
rectas sin introducción para el
transporte veloz en coche en una
exposición en nueva york' y patrocinado
por renault maurer se ven más que 24
millones de espectadores aprendieron la
lección de que la velocidad iba a ser
fuente de su liberación a través de una
maqueta enorme y vídeos promocionales
este evento efectivamente lanza la
cultura del automóvil en los eeuu la
asociación americana del automóvil
empujó la redacción de nuevas leyes
restringiendo los derechos de los
peatones en su uso de la calle
efectivamente por primera vez en la
historia se hizo delito salir de la
acera de forma irregular
claro porque quisieron abrir camino para
los coches liberar la calle de todo este
baile precioso que hemos visto en san
francisco también un consorcio de
intereses autor del mundo de del auto
compraron y desmantelaron todos los
tranvías del país desde ciudades grandes
y ciudades pequeños claro con el mismo
motivo los tranvías se entendieron como
un impedimento a la velocidad al que
tiene derecho el coche
y por supuesto la venta de los coches en
en esa época se disparó siempre con la
promesa de la escape de la ciudad no
llevar los niños al lago en el en el
bosque y ésta
y adaptación de la cultura del coche por
las masas hizo posible el desarrollo de
los grandes suburbios famosos
estadounidenses que equivalen a la
dispersión de la ciudad y el consumo
borrado del territorio y seguimos hoy en
día viendo la construcción de este tipo
de barrio a pesar de las advertencias de
liu es manfred hace 60 años de los
graves costes sociales de la dispersión
y a pesar de nuestro conocimiento hoy en
día de los graves costes ambientales de
la dispersión
pero la tragedia realmente grande es que
cada día en el mundo mueren 3 mil 280
personas en accidentes en carreteras
este es más
que un 911 cada día del año
y he hablado mucho de los eeuu país
natal mío pero realmente este modelo se
exportó por todo el mundo porque porque
esta promesa de la libertad individual a
través de el uso del coche privado se
engancha mucho
pero no es este sueño de libertad y
velocidad no es nada fácil de conseguir
de hecho en las ciudades
y dependen más de donde está mayor la
dependencia del coche privado están
experimentando un estado de colapso
perpetuo en las ciudades donde están
completamente entregados al uso del
coche sin nada más pues está hasta la
arquitectura dish totalmente
distorsionada cuando un edificio no es
viable si no lleva consigo un
apartamento capaz de tragar todos los
coches de todos los usuarios y todos los
visitantes porque no hay alternativa
pues la 1 hábitat ha hecho un estudio
muy interesante sobre la prosperidad en
las ciudades y la relación que tiene la
estructura de las calles y el primer
descubrimiento es fascinante qué
un factor clave es la superficie que
dedicamos a la calle de una superficie
total pues un territorio completo pues
en una ciudad antigua densa con una
malla de calles densa este ratio ronda
entre 30 y 40% del territorio total más
que un tercio de todo el territorio está
en las calles mientras en la ciudad
dispersa este ratio baja entre un 5 y un
15% pues es un bien público escaso otro
análisis súper interesante es la
conectividad que ofrece una red de
calles la conectividad se mide
sencillamente con una área de superficie
contando las intersecciones los puntos
azules y luego esto da una medida de
conectividad hay que restar los cul de
sac porque los cool de sex no conectan
tan solo una salida
pues esta cuestión de conectividad
equidad la oportunidad realmente y de
esto de prosperidad porque porque yo
tengo más opciones no sólo del como irme
por la ciudad pero más opciones de
encuentros más opciones de
y nuevas experiencias y eso equivale a
una movilidad social económico no solo
una movilidad físico
tuve la suerte de enseñar arquitectura y
urbanismo
en roma en unos años y este es un
ejemplo de una ciudad hiper conectada y
realmente es una delicia para el peatón
si alguien ha estado ahí es un sitio
para cambiar de este otro yo creo que no
tengo de que decir mucho más
vale una vez que tenemos el espacio de
la calle definida definido pues qué
hacemos en este espacio que usos
permitimos pues yo propongo aquí lo que
parece inevitable de nuestras calzadas y
nuestras aceras no es así es
completamente maleable aquí un antes y
un después de calles neoyorquinas y
tenemos unos ejemplos muy buenos de
personas que han atacado esta cuestión
de los usos de la de las de las calles
este puede ser el caso más famoso cuando
jane jacobs paro la destrucción de uno
de los barrios de más encanto de todo
nueva york defendiendo el espacio humano
de la calle
y hay que acordarnos que las secciones
de jay jay caps y demás sociólogos y
urbanistas no es solamente anti coches
es por uno
un espacio compartido un espacio donde
ocurren muchas cosas y dónde puede
entrar cualquier persona este es un
espacio abierto y fructífero
pues
los ejemplos en esta batalla son de
todas escalas
este es un ejemplo que me encanta que es
casi una acción guerrilla que está
diseñada para alimentar la
concienciación de que realmente los
coches representan un peligro y por qué
no pensar que la calle puede ser como un
jardín o esta actuación también un
proyecto chiquitito que roba tres o
cuatro cajones de estacionamiento y hace
en ello un lugar un lugar de encuentro
en un lugar donde pueden jugar los niños
pegados a la acera
el caso de la peatonalización de calles
centrales en ciudades congestionadas
siempre ha sido un éxito por por cada
ciudad que se hace en nueva york'
el caso es muy muy extremo lo que hizo
la comisa da del departamento de
transporte cuando realizó que tuve
derecho de cambiar realmente la vida de
los neoyorquinos con actuaciones en la
calle
la historia de ámsterdam es ejemplar me
gusta mucho la tira de debajo porque
enseña un antes de un antes de un
después y ahí vemos que lo que estamos
proponiendo humanizando la calle no es
algo nuevo es una recuperación
está comprobado que los ciclistas son
las personas más felices con su forma de
moverse por la ciudad y está comprobado
que en las ciudades donde más gente ande
por las aceras y montan en bicicleta los
ratios de obesidad de hipertensión y de
diabetes son más bajos
realmente vivir sin coches es una vida
sana
y a veces no cuesta mucho esto es
pintura un cambio de señalética y este
representa un cambio radical en el uso
del espacio de la calle y el carácter de
estas calles otra vez en nueva york'
otra cosa que se empezó en haciendo en
en bogotá colombia y se ha hecho en
muchos sitios este es el show desde el s
en parís pues es es cerrar una avenida
céntrica por un día al uso del coche
para que la gente salga y respira aire
no contaminada y experimenta una
tranquilidad y quizás pensarán que este
espacio puede ser suyo
en fin para que las calles tengan este
carácter de un sitio de encuentro tiene
que haber muchas formas de movilidad
pero estoy argumentando que todas estas
formas tienen que favorecer el peatón a
expensas del coche privado y así se crea
la calle sana
y acabo con esto que los ciudadanos
tenemos derechos y tenemos
responsabilidades y nunca deberemos
parar de salir a la calle a expresar
nuestras preferencias gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]